Bueno, como Alexander Graham Bell dijo en su memorable
primera llamada telefónica exitosa,
"Hola, ¿Domino's Pizza?"
(Risas)
Simplemente quiero darles las gracias.
Como dijo otro hombre famoso, Jerry García,
"Qué viaje más extraño y largo."
Y debería haber dicho,
"En qué extraño, largo viaje está a punto de convertirse."
En este momento, están viendo mi mitad superior.
Mi mitad inferior está en una conferencia diferente --
(Risas)
en un país diferente.
Resulta que puedes estar en dos sitios al mismo tiempo.
Aun así, lamento no poder estar con ustedes en persona.
Se lo explicaré en otra ocasión.
Y aunque soy una estrella de rock,
sólo quiero asegurarles que ninguno de mis deseos incluirá un jacuzzi.
Pero lo que realmente me emociona de la tecnología
no es sólo que podamos tener más canciones en reproductores de mp3.
La revolución -- esta revolución -- es mucho más grande que eso.
Eso espero, eso creo.
Lo que me emociona de la era digital,
lo que me emocionó personalmente,
es que se ha eliminado la distancia entre soñar y hacer.
Verán, solía ocurrir que si querías hacer un disco de una canción,
necesitabas un estudio y un productor.
Ahora, necesitas una computadora portátil.
Si querías hacer una película, necesitabas un equipo muy grande
y un presupuesto de Hollywood.
Ahora, necesitas una cámara que cabe en la palma de tu mano,
y un par de dólares para un DVD vacío.
La imaginación se ha librado de viejas limitaciones.
Y eso realmente, realmente me emociona.
Me emociona cuando veo ese tipo de pensamiento a gran escala.
Lo que me gustaría ver es al idealismo separado de toda limitación.
Política, económica, psicológica, de cualquier tipo.
El mundo geopolítico tiene mucho que aprender del mundo digital.
Desde la facilidad con la que se barrieron obstáculos
que nadie pensó que podían ser ni siquiera sorteados.
Y de eso es de lo que realmente me gustaría hablar hoy.
Aunque, primero, probablemente debería explicar por qué, y cómo,
llegué hasta aquí.
Es un viaje que empezó hace 20 años.
Tal vez recuerden esa canción, "We Are the World,"
o, "Do They Know It's Christmas?"
Band Aid, Live Aid.
Otra muy alta y canosa estrella de rock, my amigo Sir Bob Geldof,
lanzó el reto de "alimentar al mundo."
Fue un gran momento, y cambió mi vida por completo.
Ese verano, mi mujer, Ali, y yo fuimos a Etiopía.
Fuimos con discreción para ver nosotros mismos lo que pasaba.
Vivimos en Etiopía un mes, trabajando en un orfanato.
Los niños me pusieron un nombre.
Me llamaban, "La niña con barba."
(Risas)
No me pregunten.
De cualquier modo, nos pareció que África es un lugar mágico.
Cielos grandes, corazones grandes, un continente grande y brillante.
Gente buena, espléndida.
Quienquiera que haya dado algo a África ha recibido mucho más.
Etiopía no sólo me asombró, sino que me abrió la mente.
Bueno, nuestro último día en este orfanato
un hombre me dio a su hijo y dijo,
"¿Se lo llevaría con usted?"
Sabía que, en Irlanda, su hijo viviría,
y que en Etiopía, su hijo moriría.
Fue en medio de esa horrible hambruna.
Bueno, lo rechazé.
Fue una sensación rara y como enfermiza, pero lo rechazé.
Y es una sensación que jamás puedo olvidar.
Y en ese momento, empecé este viaje.
En ese momento, me convertí en lo peor de todo:
me convertí en una estrella de rock con una causa.
Sólo que esta no es la causa, ¿no?
Seis mil personas y media mueren de SIDA cada día en África --
una enfermedad que se puede prevenir y tratar --
por falta de medicamentos que nosotros podemos conseguir en una farmacia.
Esta no es una causa. Es una emergencia.
11 millones de huérfanos con SIDA en África,
20 millones al final de la década.
Esa no es una causa. Es una emergencia.
Hoy, cada día, 9.000 africanos más
contraerán VIH por el estigma y la falta de educación.
Esa no es una causa. Es una emergencia.
Así que de lo que estamos hablando aquí es de derechos humanos.
El derecho a vivir como un ser humano.
El derecho a vivir y punto.
Y a lo que nos estamos enfrentando en África es a
una amenaza a la dignidad e igualdad humanas sin precedentes.
Lo siguiente que quiero aclarar es, qué es este problema,
y qué no es.
Porque no todo se trata de caridad.
Se trata de justicia. Realmente.
No se trata de caridad. Se trata de justicia.
Eso es.
Y es una pena, porque somos muy buenos con la caridad.
Los americanos, como los irlandeses, son buenos con la caridad.
Incluso los barrios más pobres dan más de lo que pueden permitirse.
Nos gusta dar, y damos mucho.
Miren la respuesta al tsunami, es inspirador.
Pero la justicia es un standard más riguroso que la caridad.
África se ríe de nuestra idea de la justicia.
Hace una farsa de nuestra idea de la igualdad.
Se ríe de nuestras piedades. Duda de nuestro interés.
Cuestiona nuestro compromiso.
Porque no hay manera de que podamos mirar lo que sucede en África,
y, siendo sinceros,
concluir que se permitiría alguna vez que pasara en cualquier otro lugar.
Como vieron en la película, en cualquier otro lugar, menos aquí.
No aquí, no en América, no en Europa.
De hecho, un jefe de estado a quien ustedes conocen
lo admitió ante mí. Y es realmente cierto.
No hay manera de que este tipo de hemorragia de la vida humana
fuera aceptada en lugar alguno fuera de África.
África es un continente en llamas.
Y en el fondo, si aceptáramos realmente que los africanos son iguales a nosotros,
todos haríamos más para apagar las llamas.
Vamos por ahí con regaderas,
cuando lo que realmente necesitamos son los bomberos.
Verán, no es tran dramático como el tsunami.
En realidad, cuando lo piensas es una locura.
¿Es que las cosas hoy en día tienen que parecer una película de acción
para existir en nuestra mente?
La lenta extinción de incontables vidas
parece que no es lo bastante dramático.
Las catástrofes que podemos evitar
no son tan interesantes como las que podríamos evitar.
Qué gracioso.
De todas formas, creo que esa forma de pensar
es una ofensa al rigor intelectual de esta sala.
Seis mil y media personas muriendo diariamente en África puede que sea una crisis de África
pero el hecho de que no esté en las noticias de la noche,
de que nosotros en Europa, o ustedes en América,
no lo estemos tratando como una emergencia --
Esta noche quiero proponer que esta es nuestra crisis.
Quiero proponer que aunque África no está en primera línea de combate en la guerra contra el terrorismo,
podría estarlo pronto.
Cada semana, extremistas religiosos toman otro pueblo africano.
Tratan de poner en orden el caos.
Bueno, ¿por que no lo estamos haciendo nosotros?
La pobreza engendra desesperación. Eso lo sabemos.
La desesperación engendra violencia. Eso lo sabemos.
En tiempos turbulentos, ¿no es más barato, y más inteligente
hacer amigos de enemigos potenciales
que defenderte de ellos más tarde?
La guerra contra el terrorismo está ligada a la guerra contra la pobreza.
Y eso no lo he dicho yo. Lo dijo Colin Powell.
Ahora, cuando el ejército nos dice que esto es una guerra
que no puede ser ganada sólo con poder militar,
tal vez deberíamos escuchar.
Aquí hay una oportunidad, y es real.
No es una invención. No son falsas ilusiones.
Los problemas que enfrenta el mundo en desarrollo
nos permite a nosotros en el mundo desarrollado
una oportunidad para re-describirnos ante el mundo.
No sólo transformaremos las vidas de otras personas,
sino que también transformaremos cómo nos ven esas otras vidas.
Y eso puede ser inteligente en estos tiempos tensos y peligrosos.
¿No piensan que a nivel puramente comercial,
los medicamentos antirretrovirales son gran publicidad
para la ingeniosidad y la tecnología de Occidente?
¿Es que la compasión no se ve bien en nosotros?
Vayamos al grano por un segundo.
En ciertos lugares del mundo, la marca Unión Europea, la marca Estados Unidos,
no están en su mejor momento.
El letrero de neón emite zumbidos y se rompe.
Alguien ha roto la ventana con un ladrillo.
Los gerentes regionales se están poniendo nerviosos.
Occidente nunca había sido tan escrutinado.
Nuestos valores: ¿tenemos alguno?
¿Nuestra credibilidad?
Estas cosas se están atacando en el mundo.
La marca Estados Unidos se le podría pulir.
Y eso lo digo como un fan.
Como una persona que compra los productos.
Pero piensen en eso.
Que haya más antirretrovirales tiene sentido.
Pero eso es sólo la parte fácil, o debería serlo.
Pero la igualdad para África --
esa es una idea grande y cara.
Como pueden ver, la escala del sufrimiento nos insensibiliza hasta una cierta indiferencia.
¿Qué pordemos hacer todos nosotros al respecto?
Bueno, mucho más de lo que pensamos.
No podemos solucionar cada problema, pero aquellos problemas que podemos,
propongo que debemos solucionarlos.
Y porque podemos, debemos.
Esa es la verdad pura y simple.
No es una teoría.
El hecho es que nuestra generación es la primera
que puede mirar a los ojos a la enfermedad y la probreza extrema,
mirar a África a través del océano, y decir esto, y decirlo de verdad.
No tenemos que tolerar esto.
Un continente entero borrado del mapa -- no tenemos que tolerarlo.
(Aplausos)
Y déjenme que diga esto sin asomo de ironía --
antes de que vuelva a un grupo de ex hippies.
Olvídense de los 60. Podemos cambiar el mundo.
Tú no puedes, yo no puedo, individualmente, pero podemos cambiar el mundo.
A la gente en esta sala les digo, que realmente creo eso.
Miren a la Fundación Gates.
Han hecho cosas increíbles.
Pero trabajando juntos, podemos cambiar el mundo.
Podermos prevenir consecuencias inevitables,
y transformar la calidad de vida de milliones de vidas
que se ven y sienten como nosotros, cuando estamos cerca.
Lamento reirme ahora, pero ustedes se ven tan distintos
a como se veían en Haight-Ashbury en los años 60.
(Risas)
Pero quiero señalar que este es el momento para el cual ustedes fueron diseñados.
Es el florecimiento de las semillas que ustedes plantaron
en días anteriores y embriagadores.
Ideas que ustedes gestaron en su juventud.
Eso es lo que me emociona.
Esta sala nació para este momento,
eso es lo que realmente quiero decirles esta noche.
Muchos de ustedes empezaron queriendo cambiar el mundo, ¿o no?
Muchos de ustedes hicieron, el mundo digital.
Bueno, de hecho ahora, gracias a ustedes,
es posible cambiar el mundo físico.
Es un hecho.
Los economistas lo confirman, y ellos saben mucho más que yo.
Así que, ¿por qué no estamos alzando nuestros puños al aire?
Probablemente porque cuando admitimos que podemos hacer algo al respecto,
tenemos que hacer algo al respecto.
Es como una piedra en el zapato.
Esto de la igualdad es como una piedra en el zapato.
Pero por primera vez en la historia, tenemos la tecnología,
tenemos el conocimiento, tenemos el dinero,
tenemos las medicinas que salvan vidas.
¿Tenemos la voluntad?
Espero que esto sea obvio, pero no soy un hippie.
Y en realidad, a mi no me va bien eso de sentirme en las nubes.
No tengo flores en mi cabello.
De hecho, vengo del punk rock.
The Clash llevaban grandes botas militares, no sandalias.
Pero reconozco la fuerza cuando la veo.
Y en todas las charlas sobre paz y amor en la costa oeste,
hubo fuerza para el movimiento que empezó aquí.
Saben que, el idealismo separado de la acción es sólo un sueño.
Pero el idealismo aliado con el pragmatismo,
con doblarse las mangas y hacer que el mundo ceda un poco,
es muy emocionante. Es muy real. Tiene mucha fuerza.
Y está muy presente en una audiencia como ustedes.
El año pasado en DATA, esta organización que ayudé a fundar,
lanzamos una campaña para convocar este espíritu
en la lucha contra el SIDA y la pobreza extrema.
Lo llamamos la Campaña ONE (UNO).
Se basa en nuestra creencia de que la acción de una persona
puede cambiar mucho,
pero las acciones de muchos que se unen
pueden cambiar el mundo.
Bueno, pensamos que ahora es el momento de probar que tenemos razón.
Hay momentos en la historia en los que la civilización se redefine.
Creemos que éste es uno.
Creemos que éste podría ser el momento en el que el mundo finalmente decide
que la pérdida de vidas en África ya no es aceptable.
Éste podría ser el momento en el que finalmente nos tomamos en serio
cambiar el futuro para la mayor parte de la gente que vive en el planeta Tierra.
Este momento se ha ido construyendo.
Tambaleándose un poco, pero se va construyendo.
Este año es una prueba para todos nosotros,
especialmente los líderes de las naciones del G8,
que son los que realmente están al frente,
con todo el mundo mirando.
Recientemente, he estado decepcionado del gobierno de Bush.
Ellos empezaron con ciertas promesas sobre África.
Hicieron muy buenas promesas,
y de hecho cumplieron muchas de ellas.
Pero algunas no.
Ellos no sienten la presión, esa es la verdad.
Pero mi decepción tiene mucho más perspectiva
cuando hablo con gente estadounidense,
y escucho sus preocupaciones sobre el déficit,
y el bienestar fiscal del país.
Eso lo entiendo.
Pero hay mucha más presión de la que piensan,
si nos organizamos.
Lo que intento comunicar, y me pueden ayudar si están de acuerdo,
es que ayudar a África es una muy buena inversión
en una época en la que América realmente lo necesita.
Poniendolo en los términos más claros posibles,
la inversión genera grandes beneficios.
No sólo en vidas salvadas, sino en la buena voluntad, la estabilidad
y la seguridad que ganaremos.
Así que esto es lo que espero que ustedes hagan, si yo pudiera ser tan valiente
y que no me lo deduzcan de mi cantidad de deseos.
(Risas)
Lo que espero es que más allá de actos de misericordia individual,
les digan a los políticos que hagan lo correcto por África,
por América y por el mundo.
Denles permiso, si quieren,
para gastar su capital político y su capital financiero,
su monedero nacional, en salvar las vidas de millones de personas.
Eso es lo que realmente me gustaría que hicieran.
Porque también necesitamos su capital intelectual:
sus ideas, sus destrezas, su ingenio.
Y ustedes, en esta conferencia, están en una posición única.
Algunas de las tecnologías de las que hemos estado hablando, las inventaron ustedes,
o por lo menos revolucionaron la manera de usarlas.
Juntos han cambiado el espíritu de la época de lo análogo a lo digital,
y han expandido las fronteras.
Y nos gustaría que nos dieran esa energía.
Dennos esa forma de soñar, esa forma de hacer.
Como digo, aquí hay dos cosas en juego.
Está el continente africano.
Pero también está nuestro sentido de nosotros mismos.
La gente está empezando a entender esto.
Están surgiendo movimientos.
Artistas, políticos, estrellas de pop, curas, jefes de empresas,
ONGs, sindicatos de madres, de estudiantes.
Mucha gente se está uniendo, y está trabajando
bajo este paraguas del que les hablé antes, la Campaña ONE.
Creo que ellos tienen solo una idea en su mente,
la cual es; el lugar en el que vives en el mundo,
no debería determinar si vives en el mundo.
(Aplausos)
La historia, como Dios, está vigilando lo que hacemos.
Cuando se escriban los libros de historia
creo que nuestra época será recordada por tres cosas.
En serio, son sólo tres las cosas por las que se recordará esta época.
La revolución digital, sí.
La guerra contra el terrorismo, sí.
Y lo que hicimos o no hicimos por apagar los incendios en África.
Algunos dicen que no podemos permitírnos hacer algo. Yo digo que no podemos permitirnos no hacerlo.
Gracias, muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Okay, mis tres deseos.
Los que TED se ha ofrecido a cumplir.
Verán, si es cierto, y yo creo que lo es,
que el mundo digital que todos ustedes han creado ha liberado
a la imaginación creativa de los límites físicos de la materia.
Esto debería ser pan comido.
(Risas)
Debería añadir que esto empezó como una lista de deseos mucho más larga.
La mayoría imposibles, algunos poco prácticos
y uno o dos ciertamente inmorales.
(Risas)
Esto es adictivo, ustedes saben lo que quiero decir,
cuando es otro quien paga los platos rotos.
Bueno, aquí está el número uno.
Deseo que ustedes ayuden a construir un movimiento social
de más de un millón de activistas americanos por África.
Ese es mi primer deseo.
Creo que es posible.
Hace unos minutos, hablé de todas las campañas de ciudadanos que están surgiendo.
Ustedes saben, hay muchas por ahí.
Y con esta campaña como nuestro paraguas,
mi organización, DATA, y otros grupos,
han estado usando la energía y el entusiasmo
de la calle, desde Hollywood hasta el corazón de América.
Sabemos que hay energía más que suficiente para alimentar este movimiento.
Sólo necesitamos su ayuda para hacer que suceda.
Les queremos a todos aquí, la América regiliosa, la América corporativa,
la América de Microsoft, la América de Apple, la América de Coca Cola,
la América de Pepsi, la América inteligente, la América ruidosa.
No podemos permanecer fríos y no participar en esto.
Creo que si construimos un movimiento fuerte de un millón de americanos
no seremos ignorados.
El Congreso nos escuchará.
Estaremos en la primera página del boletín informativo de Condi Rice,
y de ahí al Despacho Oval.
Si hay un millón de americanos --y esto lo sé de verdad--
que están dispuestos a llamar por teléfono,
que están dispuestos a estar conectados a internet.
Estoy completamente seguro de que podemos cambiar
el curso de la historia, literalmente, para el continente africano.
Así que me gustaría que nos ayudaran a firmar eso.
Sé que ya contamos con John Cage y Sun Microsystems,
pero hay muchos de ustedes con los que nos gustaría hablar.
Claro, mi segundo deseo, el número dos.
Me gustaría que se publicara una noticia por
cada persona que vive con menos de un dolar al día en el planeta.
Eso es un billón de noticias.
Podría ser en Google, en AOL.
Steve Case, Larry, Sergey -- ya han hecho mucho.
Podría ser en NBC. Podría ser en ABC.
De hecho hoy vamos a hablar con ABC sobre los Oscars.
Tenemos una película, producida por Jon Kamen en Radical Media.
Pero ustedes saben, nosotros queremos, necesitamos algo de tiempo en directo para nuestras ideas.
Necesitamos que las matemáticas, que las estadísticas lleguen al pueblo americano.
Sinceramente creo en la vieja frase de Truman,
que si al pueblo americano le das los hechos,
ellos harán lo correcto.
Y la otra cosa importante, es que esto no es Sally Struthers.
Esto tiene que describirse cono una aventura, no como una carga.
(Video): uno a uno van avanzando,
una enfermera, un profesor, un amo de casa,
y se salvan vidas.
El problema es enorme.
Una persona muere cada tres segundos.
Y en otros tres segundos, una más.
La situación es tan desesperante en partes de África,
Asia, incluso América
que los grupos de ayuda, como hicieron cuando el tsunami,
se están uniendo como si fueran uno, están actuando como si fueran uno.
Podemos derrotar a la pobreza extrema, al hambre, al SIDA.
Pero necesitamos su ayuda.
Una persona más, una palabra más, una voz más,
será la diferencia entre la vida y la muerte
de millones de personas.
Por favor, únanse a nosotros para trabajar juntos.
Los americanos tienen una oportunidad sin precedentes.
Podemos hacer historia.
Podemos empezar a hacer que la pobreza sea historia.
Uno a uno, uno a uno.
Por favor, visiten ONE en esta dirección.
No les pedimos dinero. Les pedimos su voz.
Bien. Espero que TED verdaderamente muestre el poder de la información.
El poder de reescribir las reglas y transformar vidas,
al conectar cada hospital, las clínicas y las escuelas
en un país africano.
Y me gustaría que fuera Etiopía.
Creo que podemos conectar cada escuela en Etiopía,
cada clínica, cada hospital.
Podemos conectarnos a internet.
Ese es mi deseo, mi tercer deseo.
Creo que es posible.
Creo que en la sala tenemos el dinero y la inteligencia para hacer eso.
Y ese sería un deseo deslumbrante si se cumpliera.
Como dije antes, he estado en Etiopía.
De hecho, es donde todo empezó para mí.
La idea de que el internet, que cambió la vida de todos nosotros,
pueda cambiar un país -- y un continente
que apenas ha llegado a la época análoga, no hablemos de la digital -- me asombra.
Pero no empezó así.
La primera línea a distancia desde Boston a Nueva York
se usó en 1885 por teléfono.
Tan solo nueve años más tarde Addis Ababa
estaba conectada por teléfono a Harara, que está a 500 kilómetros.
Desde entonces, no ha cambiado mucho.
El tiempo de espera promedio para conseguir una línea de teléfono fijo en Etiopía
es alrededor de siete u ocho años.
Pero la tecnología inalámbrica ni se había imaginado en aquel entonces.
Bueno, soy irlandés, y como pueden ver,
sé qué tan importante es hablar.
La comunicación es muy importante para Etiopía -- transformará el país.
Las enfermeras recibiendo mejor preparación,
los farmacéuticos siendo capaces de ordenar suplementos médicos,
los médicos compartiendo su pericia en todos los campos de la medicina.
Es una idea muy, muy buena idea que estén conectados.
Y ese es mi tercer y último deseo para ustedes en la conferencia TED.
Muchas gracias nuevamente.
(Aplausos)